howdy I'm Max Keiser this is the Kaiser
report we won't talk about breaks it but
except I was right it was a total
shambles from day one as I predicted but
we won't go into that Stacy that's a
tedious story to cover as well so let's
talk about the flawless rally that is
the title of this episode and first I
want to look at ahead well it's actually
a tweet from Matt Odell who's in the
Bitcoin space and he says so many people
surprised that rich people have been
buying credentials wait until they
realize how our money works ignorant is
bliss until it isn't of course you and I
here on Kaiser report have been talking
about this and it's a very interesting
story it's much more fascinating than
most other stories and that's the
Cantillon effect because remember that
you know the masters of our financial
universe whether they're in the Treasury
Department's the presidential palace or
the Federal Reserve White Tower the
ivory tower
you know they will say that they're
printing money exclusively for the top
you know 0.1% the bankers that that is a
you know victimless crime there's
nothing bad that happens and but in fact
the cantle in effect happens and we see
the likes of the yellow vest movement we
see the consequences of the wealth and
income gap and that is what this guy
Matt Odell is saying is when people were
shocked to discover that the wealthy are
buying their way into these universities
the same thing is happening all around
you is the wealthy or wealthy partly
especially in now and that today's age
is because of the assets that the
Federal Reserve is pumping up well the
cost of bribing your way into a college
is something like five hundred thousand
dollars now put that into context the
central bank says that they recently
print money is to stimulate inflation
that there's not enough aggregate demand
and that prices aren't moving and yet
the price of bribing your way into
college at $500,000 a clip surely shows
that there is inflation the cost of
health care skyrocketing costs of
education even without bribing your way
in is skyrocketing there's purchasing
power collapse which is the same thing
as inflation
and the central bank that that's the
intellectual cover that they say that
they're doing they're printing the money
to stimulate aggregate them in that's
what they will write about in the Wall
Street Journal what they're doing
however is they are using the central
banks as a transfer mechanism to take
billions of dollars from savers and
workers and put it into the pockets of
charlatans crooks speculators Spivs
Hollywood celebrities etc trying to
bribe their way into Ivy League I mean
that's that's what the central bank's
function is at this moment as a transfer
mechanism and then the intellectual mean
that they put out there to try to cover
this crime is to say that they're trying
to stimulate aggregate demand it's yes
and it's also we have this notion of a
meritocracy not only in this educational
space and you rise to the top only
because you weren't it but a lot of
people think that they are somehow
uniquely endowed with a great business
intelligence if and you see that in the
comments sections on anything having to
do with housing bubbles that they think
that the fact that somebody bought one
of those public housing that Margaret
Thatcher sold off to the speculators in
the 80s right now those prices and those
houses are going to have $80,000 a year
and they think that they're uniquely
endowed that they somehow have achieved
this and that they are uniquely
qualified to receive this wealth free
from the rest of the economy I it's the
money printing that's causing these
housing bubbles in the cities and in the
stock markets and so I do think you do
see this polarization that's part of the
polarization there are many reasons for
the polarization but one of the reasons
is this and you I think if you look
around the world you do see a conflict
emerging between the the winners of the
cities all the winners in San Francisco
Los Angeles New York Cleveland it's
Chicago any city you know they voted for
Hillary Clinton and she called them the
winners the losers outside the money
printing the the last to get all that
new money they're the losers and they're
angry and
you know the winners control the media
so they'll say well those people are
racist there and we should basically
lock them up and D platform them but at
the end of the day maybe if we stop
printing money and giving free money to
just the people who live in cities and
actually just either stop printing money
or give money equally to everybody
well like Ben Bernanke had a deal with
the guy who heads up Citadel Capital Ben
Bernanke gave this guy two hundred and
million dollars to buy an apartment in
New York essentially right and he took
the money and he bought this apartment
it's the most ever paid for an apartment
and then he turned around and hired Ben
Bernanke to work for Citadel capital
once he left the Federal Reserve that's
right I mean that's and now he's leading
the charge because New York City because
he doesn't live there in New York City
he lives in Chicago but now they want to
start taxing people basically a property
tax on people who don't live there a
wealth tax on people who don't actually
live there in New York City so don't pay
state or city taxes so his property he
bought for two hundred and fifty million
dollars he's like he's fight he's
leading the charge against it but you
know despite all this money printing and
the stock prices going up higher and
higher and higher and higher here's a
tweet from Tracy alloway another analyst
warning of the flawless rally Citigroup
joins Goldman and JP Morgan and warning
the equities rally hasn't been matched
by inflows into equity funds buybacks
not investor inflows now drive the US
market and you know for me if I look at
this it goes exactly what that Cantillon
effect and the central bank's printing
money only allowed to go to a certain
segment of the population is we have a
flawless economy there money is not
circulating we have you know the the
circulation the velocity of money is at
all-time lows like money's not leaving
their hands that ken Griffith of the
world are just buying two hundred and
fifty million dollar properties and
he'll pay five hundred million for the
same property next year as long as it
keeps going up and he has a safe haven
for it it's not gonna flow into the
economy right the money velocity is dead
right so the money velocity would
measured of how money is being loaned
out
from bank to bank to bank to bank to
bank which is a measure of economic
health is dead and if the money printing
continues to increase so instead of
asking the question why is the money not
getting into the economy they're
printing more of it doubling down on
that mistake because they don't want to
they don't want to look at why the
money's not getting to the economy
because the banks are handing billions
hundreds of billions and trillions to
their friends that's what we that's what
we're seeing and that the friends god
they buy a two hundred fifty million
dollar apartment or they spend two
hundred million dollars or four hundred
million dollars on an event on a da
Vinci like was recently purchased I
think you know the money is not flowing
down to the economy because also you
know as a banker that you're the ones
that get the free money so are you gonna
lend to Joe bag of doughnuts out on the
street who's you know for a fact is
never gonna get the free money so you're
gonna lend to one of your friends right
who's gonna be guaranteed you be able to
pay you back
that's where the money is staying
circulating in the top of the economy
because the way it's set up
it's never gonna flow to the bottom the
era of cheap money shows no one knows
how monetary policy works monetary
policy is supposed to work like this
cut interest rates and you'll encourage
businesses and households to borrow
invest and spend it's not really playing
out that way and the cheap money error
now into its second decade in most of
the developed world and third decade in
Japan there's been plenty of borrowing
but it's been government's doing it of
course all the free money is going to
the top who again it's not the same old
economy they're not gonna lend to
anybody out there they're just gonna
keep it to themselves and lent buy
shares back and learn to buy more
property not all around the world but in
major cities where they know more the
free money flows into look if I'm a
farmer and I need to irrigate my fields
and I have a big tanker full of water
and the tanker shows up and they're
irrigating my field into the irrigation
system but none of the water is getting
into the field it's for some reason
stuck at the level of the tanker and
then I go over when I see that the guy
who brought the tanker over to irrigate
my field is selling the water to a
banker on Wall Street who then is
to another farmer somewhere claiming
that he's gonna irrigate their field but
somehow it never gets irrigated either
it's in another tanker and then that
tanker full of water is sold to yet
another central banker somewhere else in
the world and they all work together and
they all claim that there's no growth in
the fields that the fields are dying we
don't understand why because they're
stealing all the water in this case
liquidity or the liquidity of the money
is not getting into the economy because
they're stealing it and that is so
freakin obvious how I mean a OSE right
she's smart she understands now a little
bit how things work if she drills down
into this she will find a nest of vipers
like she's never ever imagined before do
it do it now well it's beyond that it's
more like idiocracy where it's not even
water they're pumping in it's just
kool-aid and even if it you know it's
because it's toxic fake Assad's debt
it's not it's nothingness and that's why
they won't allow it to go into the
economy because the the population
basically knows it's all fake money and
this article here points out that part
of the reason is we have Parliament's we
have Congress we have the Senate and
people voters all those people you see
walking around across the entire US they
vote for those people to represent them
but what the bankers have achieved is
like we have the independence of the
central bank they are independent of all
youth voters out there they don't abide
by politicians they don't listen to
politicians they're independent ie they
just work for us they just work for this
handful of guys mostly that work on Wall
Street and that's who they work for and
we have somehow allowed this situation
where we say oh like we're so in all of
them Wow look how rich Warren Buffett he
just like keeps making tens of billions
a year
he's like magical he's brilliant and one
day that kool-aid will trickle down to
us but the fact is this because the
independent central bank gives these
people money so basically this article
in Bloomberg is suggesting that perhaps
fiscal policy you know we set fiscal
policy even in the Constitution that
says
only the you know the federal government
can the Treasury can print money that in
that and if a state chooses to it has to
be in gold or silver because they can't
bankrupt the federal government but now
we have a situation whereby bankers can
print as much money as they want and it
doesn't have to be backed by anything
and they thus bankrupt the central
government our federal government us the
taxpayers are on the hook for it that's
a good point you know the banks can when
they make a loan they print that money
that's not from reserves they're not
lending money out that's in the bank to
a business that's come from deposits
that they have no reserves they have
negative reserves they just loan them
when they loan out for a mortgage or a
business they print that money into
existence that's why the debt goes to 22
trillion dollars over time and you're
right they are it's the old savings
alone trickled the old FDIC trick is
like you know the government's gonna
bail you out no matter how much of a
serial fraudster you are and then
federal government always bails them out
because who makes the regulations the
same bankers yes again that's why it's
in the Constitution the Constitution
mentions gold and silver as money only
for the state if the state wants to
trade with France and go into debt it
must be backed by their currency must be
backed by gold and silver so they don't
bankrupt the citizens and residents of
the other states of the United States so
here we have a situation exactly what
was warned about in the Constitution if
we have these people allowed to rack up
as much debt as possible and we are on
the hook for it that's not right any got
to take a break when we come back much
more
welcome back to the Kaiser report I'm
Max Keiser time now to go to Alistair
McLeod of gold money.com
as always full disclosure I have an
investment in gold money and you know
Alistair we turned to you for the macro
picture the big picture the big
geopolitical macro view of things
welcome back
it's very nice feedback thanks max
alrighty let's start with Mario draggy
he recently said that negative interest
rates in Europe have quote worked quite
well your response well I don't think so
at all I mean attacks on them on
deposits just doesn't make any sense I
think basically he's got a problem and
that is he's got no other armory than
just printing money trying to make money
look as cheap as possible taking it into
negative interest rates try and do
everything to stimulate the economy and
it doesn't work because all that happens
is the money just ends up in the
financial sector it ends up going to
finance government debt it doesn't do
anything for the underlying economy and
of course meanwhile the you know the
euros in your hand are being diluted the
whole time so there's a transfer of
wealth if you like from the productive
sector to the government until necessary
extent to the financial sector right
let's look at the verbiage for a second
because these words are misused some
would argue so when you say the argument
for these policies are to quote
stimulate the economy that's really a
misnomer isn't it because they are not
stimulating the economy in the sense
that they're making credit available to
small to medium enterprises right you're
absolutely right I mean I use stimulus
in the Keynesian sense which I think you
and I would agree is actually nonsense
how could you stimulate an economy by
transferring wealth from ordinary people
to the government I mean it just doesn't
happen it's you know it's a
contradiction and this is the
contradiction which the ECB is having to
live with I mean I'm sure if you spoke
to individual
members of the ECB you will find that
their shaking their head saying well you
know what else can we do this is
terrible and nothing we do works and of
course we realize what's going on but
you know our mandate is that we have got
to continue to print money to keep
things going that's and they're stuck in
this ridiculous situation right now
after we've been talking about this for
a few years now and people say well when
is this going to happen and correct me
if I'm wrong but isn't this already
happening when we see protests like the
yellow vests in France burning banks
down attacking Phuket's luxury
restaurants attacking and burning the
Bank of France we see the yellow vests
just appearing in London for the first
time we see this global insurrection
against banker occupation so isn't the
result of this faulty monetary policy
happening right now I'll stir well I
think it is the problem is that the
people who are protesting don't actually
understand money they don't understand
why why and how they have been robbed by
their governments and in France you've
got the extra problem and that is that
everybody's left-wing profit is a dirty
word they just they've got nowhere to go
intellectually in terms of understanding
the condition that their government has
put them in and as for yellow vests I
think Stacy very kindly tweeted
something earlier there's a yellow vest
protest in London but then I think has
more to do with the portion and all the
rest of it I mean these are crazies
basically now I sympathize with them
because nobody likes to be robbed but
you know at least trying to understand
what is going on that's my message to
the yellow vests right and to your point
there for a second the yellow vests and
other protest movements around the world
might not actually understand the
connection to monetary policy and for
that reason because they are a bit
intellectually misinformed
they resort to things like socialism
which is very easy to explain but never
ever works now I want to talk about
interest rates for a second air so
ambassadors are betting that rate cuts
are in the cards for 2019 but the US
Federal Reserve Bank is all
indicated that they may in fact join the
negative interest rate bandwagon oh my
god Alice are your thoughts well we've
had a lot of stuff recently I mean
they've been pushing mmt as well
again the Federer in the hole I mean
they started trying to reduce their
balance sheet really anticipating the
day when they might need to expand it
again and they didn't get very far with
that before suddenly they had to put
everything to us you know to a halt the
problem that we face globally is one of
cycles
you've got the credit cycle which is
know peaked I think that is becoming
clear as we have seen that the global
economy has definitely slowed down but
on top of that you've got another factor
and that is trade protectionism now the
last time we had a combination of trade
protectionism and the credit cycle as it
speak coming off its peak was in 1929
and in October 1929 they passed the
smoot-hawley Tariff Act this is Congress
on the 30th of October in the month of
October when traders in the market could
see what was happening the market fell
34% and this led us into obviously the
slump I mean between 1929 and 1932 the
Dow lost about 90 percent of its value I
mean we face exactly the same
combination today now obviously we hope
that it doesn't if you like share that
1929 to 32 as a precedent for what's
going on today but it's getting
increasingly difficult to argue that it
you know that it's not a precedent it
looks to me as if this combination of
cycles could be extremely damaging to
the global economy and of course the
idea that you can manage your way out of
the situation by fiddling around with
interest rates mmt negative rates
whatever it might be is is a complete
fallacy right let's talk about cycles
for a second there is of course the
business cycle and that would indicate
that when prices get too high and credit
gets too easy
that there's a contraction and you have
a downturn in
it's very healthy in a capitalist
economy but we haven't had those in many
years now because we have activist
central banks that print money no matter
what our Keynesianism if you will and
now my point is this that it makes sense
that we're at an inflection point in a
cycle and then you read the following
China and now saying that they're gonna
get into the quantitative easing game so
okay here's China now coming in gonna
print lots of money to keep the Ponzi
scheme going Nomi Prins in her excellent
book collusion lays out the exact way
all these central banks around the world
collude with each other there's never
ever been enough anything but a lot of
free money for the last 30 years isn't
this just gonna prolong this extension
of the bubble if China gets into the
quantitative easing game Alastor well
it's already prolonged the bubble I
think also we need to draw a distinction
between what's going on in China and
what's going on in the rest of the world
if you look at China it's a relatively
new economy dumb debt to GDP is around
about 40 percent its welfare commitments
are not all that great they have some
but it's not that great is controllable
so in the event of a general crisis
China actually is more strong
financially than the welfare dependent
states such as America UK Italy France
and all the rest of it the problem in
America has if I can use it as a
talisman for the rest of us because
we're in exactly the same position is
that America's now got a debt to GDP of
above 100% on top of that she has got a
budget deficit at the top of what you
call the business cycle I call it a
credit cycle at a time when according to
Keynesian mythology as it were the
government deficit should actually be a
surplus because of tax revenue and all
the rest of it I mean we've got a
problem now that you got a reversal
going on in global trade flows so that
the foreigners are no longer going to be
financing the US trade deficit what this
means is that last year in other words
fiscal 2018 I think
domestic investors had to find something
like a hundred and eighty billion
dollars to finance the the balance of
the trade deficits that sorry the budget
deficit which is not covered by capital
recycling from the trade deficit now
that's gone into reverse if you don't
look at the tick figures for the last
two months around about two hundred and
fifty seven billion dollars has left the
dollar America if you like now most of
that miss Italy is in the private sector
with only about twenty billion in the
public sector by public sector I mean
you know governments and so on and so
forth
but you can see this if that continues
not only you're going to have to find
the money for about one and a half
trillion dollars of extra government
debt but you know gone
you no longer got the foreigners buying
it and worse still the foreigners are
selling it so you can see that if you
look at the situation in China not good
but it's not nearly as bad as it is in
America and now it also Vantage's to
suggest that we have the same problems
here and they have the same problems in
Europe right the just talk about the
budget deficit for a second in the u.s.
just the interest on that that even with
this low low interest rate environment
is approaching half a trillion dollars
so that's obviously not sustainable and
when you can't even pay the interest on
your debt that's usually when you end up
in a hyperinflationary currency meltdown
but to your point about China so in if
you're saying that in the okay Corral of
weak economies and they enter the global
economy shoot out that the one standing
is China it's not strong but it's what
it is relative to the other other
countries around the world Alistair the
Chinese can make some horrendous
mistakes so you know let's just put that
to one side for the moment but China
actually has a plan which I think can
keep it going for a while and the
interesting thing is that while as you
point out the the budget deficits lead
to huge great interest cost in America
and you're going to get rising bond
yields by the way as
well as a result of the oncoming
recession strokes slump and I think it
will be a slump the situation in China
is somewhat different because what they
can do they have got enough gold to put
themselves on a gold standard and what
that means is that if they can do that
successfully and it's it's not
necessarily a straightforward thing to
do but they have got the means to do it
because they don't have the debt
problems at the government level they
don't have the welfare commitments that
the Americans and we have and so on and
so forth they could actually put their
currency on a gold standard and what
that means is that the interest rates
that they have to pay on their 40% of
GDP which is debt would be tied to the
gold interest rate rather than a fiat
currency which is collapsing type
interest rate and that's going to be a
huge great problem I think in the coming
year or two right that's incredible you
know the fact is that even though China
only has maybe less than half of the
gold of the US they have a fraction the
tiny fraction of the debt so yeah I
guess using those numbers you could come
up with the idea of China going on a
gold standard for readily all right well
I'll stir mcleod thanks so much for your
time once again and being on the Kaiser
report that's my pleasure max all righty
and that is going to do it for this
edition of the Kaiser report with mwah
Max Keiser and Stacy Herbert if you want
to catch us on twitter it's Kaiser
report until next time bye all
[Music]